russia says it is now in full control of
the azov-style steel works in mario paul
ukrainian soldiers had held onto the
plant for weeks despite being surrounded
by russian forces and facing constant
bombardment
ukrainian officials ordered them to
surrender hoping this would save their
lives
they've been evacuating for days
but the siege of this symbolic
battleground appears to be finally over
in a video released the commander of the
as of battalion says they've been
ordered to abandon the defense of
mariopol
our commanders have given the order to
save the lives of the men and to abandon
the defense of the city
work is underway to bring the bodies of
the killed fighters out
so that ukraine can bury its heroes
defense experts fear there will now
likely be a relocating of russian forces
troops from mariopol could now support
the offensive in other parts of eastern
ukraine
where the russian assault is continuing
in full force
russian state television broadcast
images of an offensive in luhansk
ukraine's president vladimir zelensky
says the bombardment of the donbass
region has been brutal
this is a deliberate and criminal
attempt to kill as many ukrainians as
possible
to destroy as many homes social
institutions and businesses as possible
this is genocide of the ukrainian people
and the occupiers will be held
accountable and brought to justice
the governor of the lehansk region which
is still under ukrainian control has
reported further attacks where more
people have been killed
well dw correspondent matthias bullinger
is in kramertorsk that's a city in the
donbass region about 50 kilometers from
the fighting
i asked him for an update on the
situation in the city
well uh it's already past curfew so now
i'm in the backyard of my hotel and
the city is eerily quiet and today and
even in the daytime we've never seen
more than three or four people on the
street and there was the absolute
maximum usually you see no one most of
the people have left this city because
it's the administrative center of the
donbass region of those parts that are
under ukrainian control and there were
of course expectations that something
might happen here the city has been hit
by rockets before there was an attack on
the railway station in the beginning of
april where many civilians trying to
flee the city died and since then more
and more people have left fighting is
going on mostly
north north northeast of here in sierra
donetsk that's another administrative
center in this region uh shelling there
is heavy people die every day and uh
much of the city has already been
destroyed
right
and uh
both sides now uh ukraine and russia
have now confirmed that the azov style
steel plant is in russian hands and what
are you hearing
yeah it's what i have been hearing as
well of course the ukrainian the fight
the other battalions commander has
released a message today where they have
said that
they have had the order to to give up
and to save the their lives um and not
to continue fighting under these
conditions where they cannot win
anything they cannot get out there's
nothing they can do they can just hold
on until basically basically they die
there um so they've been given the order
to give up which means to
go into
to give up to to surrender to the
russians and russia has now said that
all of those who remained 500 had
had surrendered needs confirmation from
the ukrainian side but it's in line with
what we've been hearing before right i
know you're in khaki earlier where
russian troops have been driven back
from the outskirts of the city now
authorities there are keen to restore a
normal life
we'll take a look at your report and
then come back to you matias
they came here to flee the bombs and now
they don't want to leave people who have
been living in the subway station are
petitioning the government to let them
stay subway stations here in kharkiv
have been serving as bomb shelters since
the beginning of the war
katarina talpa and her husband have been
living here since the very first day
i go home every three weeks
but i always need to prepare myself
mentally before i can go
then i run home and take a bath we can
wash here but the conditions are not
ideal
others don't have a choice they do not
have a place to go back to anymore
this station is the terminal station of
the metro line the northernmost station
in the city it's closest to the front
line and to those areas that have been
most heavily shelled
the shelling of kharkiv has all but
subsided and the local government wants
to get the subway system running again
it wants the people to leave the metro
and is offering to relocate them but
many here don't trust the peace
around the subway station many of the
houses have been destroyed and some
streets barely a house has been
untouched olga has also spent the past
months in the subway it's the first time
she's come back to see the apartment
where she lived with her mother and her
son
she was told that there was damage but
she didn't know how bad it was
it's terrible
the shell hits a wall in one of the
rooms there's debris everywhere
she documents everything people can
report the damage on the government
website but nobody knows how long it
will take to get any support
my knees are shaking my knees are
actually shaking i still can't believe
it i knew that the windows were broken
if only that shell hadn't hit yeah if
there wasn't this hole in the wall we
might still somehow move back the house
is still standing but this is different
for now the only thing to do is to
collect some of their belongings they
will not move back to the subway but to
a relative's house
some distressing personal stories there
matthias what sort of state is the city
in
well it depends on where you are in this
city so these northern suburbs this
house where she was standing is just
it's the last house on the border of the
town and just behind we could look out
of the window you see fields and then
villages and these villages were
occupied by the russian so
they were just able to to shell from
everything they have everything
basically would hit at one of these
houses because it was so close and these
areas are basically i don't know whether
they'll ever be inhabited but probably
you have you will have to tear
everything down before they will be
and rebuild it before it will be
possible to live there for most houses
they've been severely damaged other
parts of the city are not that bad hit
there were a few rocket hits at the
center you see the city is wounded
wherever you walk and people life is
really returning slowly to the city much
slower than for example in kiev after
the troops were driven back from the
border of kiev basically
um life was returning already but
here it's different because the right
the fighting is still ongoing it's
further from the city and the shells
don't hit the city anymore but
it's still ongoing so people are much
more careful to go back and many shops
are still closed and it takes some time
for people to readjust to the situation
okay thank you for that matthias
bulinger in kramer tursk
and we can talk to liabov tipulska who
is a political analyst and advisor to
the ukrainian government and military
she joins us from akiv a welcome to dw
and what do you think prompted uh keith
to order those soldiers in as of style
to surrender
first of all i think that
our soldiers our military
in azo plan they accomplished their
mission
they fought
fiercely and selflessly they fought to
the last
bullet to the last ammunition they
did everything possible to evacuate
civilians wounding civilians
and the wounded military
so
if they did this step that it may it
means that um there was uh no other
choice for that right and uh
the whole ukrainian perceives them as
our heroes i understood but i i suppose
that given that the the prisoners have
been coming out of there um over these
last few days one wonders well why today
why not yesterday
uh why today because uh the situation
was changing every day i think and uh
it was their decision and uh at that
moment it was it it
feels and it felt right right thank you
for giving me for interrupting you i
just want to be clear what what you said
that you said this was the decision of
the soldiers in azerstal rather than
them responding to uh orders from kiev
no it was a joint decision obviously the
main goal was to save lives
and
for many of them it was one possible way
to do it understood uh what do you think
happens to them now talk of a prisoner
swap seems to have died down
we do not know uh for sure what is
happening to them uh we see we observe a
lot of disinformation online on it issue
uh but and details of uh these
negotiations are not disclosed
so um i think it's going to be another
opportunity
for us and for the whole world to see
whether russia is sticking to the
agreements so far history has shown that
russia
always violates any agreements
but as far as you understand
those talks about a prisoner stop are
still going on
uh yes we keep hearing this but we also
observe a lot of uh information
especially on russian domain on uh
prosecuting them so we
do not have a clear vision what is going
to happen
and now that russian troops aren't tied
up in mariopol the fear is that they'll
be deployed to step up the assault on
donbass
what's your feeling
i think that the amount of troops
russian troops at that area was not very
significant so if they are deployed to
um
other parts of eastern ukraine it's not
going to change
the whole situation
anderson thank you so much for joining
us uh above uh tipolska advisor to the
ukrainian government thank you
thank you
some other developments uh in this war
starting in germany where the defense
ministry says it will develop it will
deliver the first of its 15 gephard or
cheetah anti-air tanks to ukraine in
july kiev has been pleading for more
heavy weaponry to battle russian troops
in the east critics accused germany of
taking too long to deliver military aid
several people have been injured in a
russian strike on a ukrainian culture
center president zielenski released this
surveillance footage of the attack on
the town of lazava in the eastern region
of hakeef he said russian forces
deliberately targeted the center ukraine
has accused russia of routinely striking
civilian targets
now g7 ministers have warned that the
war is causing global economic
disruptions impacting energy supply of
food production and export as well as
the functioning of supply chains around
the world
ukraine accuses russia of deliberately
targeting food supply infrastructure
russian missiles took out a grain
warehouse in eastern ukraine on thursday
officials say the storage facility south
east of zapposia is now completely
unusable
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
has accused russia of using food as a
weapon with global consequences
ukraine's one of the world's most
important suppliers of grain and
sunflower oil but russia's blockade of
black sea ports has halted shipments
the colours of ukraine the country's
endless golden wheat fields are
reflected in its flag
but russia's invasion means some of
ukraine's rich farmland now looks like
this
ukraine has accused russia of
deliberately targeting its agriculture
sector tearing up fields planting
landmines and destroying equipment and
warehouses
in safer parts of the country farmers
have been tasked with planting extra
crops in a bid to make up for the losses
elsewhere
but the threat to food security goes far
beyond ukraine
the country is one of the world's
biggest exporters of food products like
wheat corn and sunflower oil
but russia has blocked ukraine's key
ports leaving it unable to ship vital
food supplies
without our agricultural exports dozens
of countries in different parts of the
world are already on the brink of food
shortages
and over time the situation could become
frankly speaking terrible
politicians are already discussing the
possible consequences of the sharp rise
in prices famine in african countries
asian countries
russia has blamed the situation on
western sanctions
but some experts suggest russia is
manipulating grain markets using wheat
as a bargaining chip to its own
advantage
as the world's number one wheat exporter
there are warnings russia could withhold
its own wheat exports for political gain
according to the world food programme
around four and a half million tons of
grain is stuck in silos at ukrainian
ports
it's particularly disastrous for
countries already suffering from food
shortages
yemen for example gets more than half of
its wheat from ukraine and russia
this
war the ukraine war has
is overlapping the impact is overlapping
with
a crisis that has already been unfolding
in several countries
the eu is now racing to work out
alternative routes across land to secure
supply chains
meanwhile the un is leading negotiations
to get shipping routes reopened and get
vital food supplies to where they're
desperately needed
let's look at this with michael kimmich
he's professor of history at the
catholic university of america and a
fellow of the german martial fund he
served as an expert on russia and
ukraine for president obama's state
department welcome to dw um
looking at what's going on there
is this a pattern that you see do you do
you see russia deliberately creating
food shortages around the world as part
of this war
i'm not sure if it's a deliberate
creation of a food shortage it's
certainly a consequence of the war and i
don't think that russia will lift its
naval embargo of ukraine for for many
reasons what it will try to do is to
exploit this crisis to make it the fault
of
western intransigence nato expansion and
such it will try to use it for
propaganda purposes
everyone's at this propaganda game
though aren't they because you know the
west is there imposing sanctions on
russia regarding it as a legitimate uh
tactic to try and uh bring down its
banking system
uh
and and of course
if we can do that why shouldn't russia
try to uh do the same with whatever
tools it has at its disposal
well i don't think that western policy
is to bring down russia's banking system
the
goal of the sanctions policy is to
limit the development of russia's war
machine uh so it's a it's it's it's
targeted uh and i don't think that um
you know sort of sabotaging the world's
food supply as a proportional response
uh to that so these are two separate
tracks i would say uh but yes all of
this is a feature of widening tension
between russia and the west uh and
that's uh going to be a very long term
phenomenon with many many negative
consequences
so let's pick up about that idea of each
side blaming the the other as i say that
the west imposes those sanctions on
russian fuel and the banking system uh
and uh
russia and its uh its apologists and its
friends uh say well this is the west
side so we'll hear from china's
permanent representative to the united
nations
weaponizing economic interdependence
will only create artificial difficulties
and amplify local risks
we call for the lifting of unilateral
sanctions and restrictions on food
production and exports as soon as
possible so as to stabilize and smooth
food production and supply
michael kimmich do you buy that the west
removes its sanctions and russia lets
the grain out of ukrainian ports and the
problem goes away seems to go that
thinking
uh it doesn't really make any sense from
a western point of view
the sanctions are there because of the
war
in the violations of ukrainian
sovereignty and i think uh
it's for that reason that the sanctions
have to have to stay if something can be
worked out about the grain uh that would
be excellent but it wouldn't be through
uh sanctions relief that's just not
gonna it's not gonna happen on the
western side and it shouldn't because
it's not connected to the stated aims of
the sanctions policy
okay so both sides say it's your fault
and we're not moving um i wonder if you
could just
expand on an idea that was that was
touched on in our report that russia
could also withhold its own wheat from
the market for political gain because on
the face of it this seems like the last
thing that a cash-strapped severely
sanctioned country with limited access
to international markets would
do it's very true it doesn't seem like
there's any reputational gain in russia
in doing that they would just seem a
less reliable supplier of grain to those
parts of the world that consume russian
grain so it would be an odd policy
unless the russian calculation is that
this instability
uh that the global grain shortage is
going to cause that the instability is
so useful to russia uh that it would do
it for that sake but that you know seems
like a very um
a very uh unusual policy putting it
mildly well this has been an unusual
conflict hasn't it because on the one
side okay we we have what we understand
we have the the the bombs and the
bullets are flying but on the the other
we have all these other weapons being
used um there whether it be the the food
or fuel and and the rest of it this
we're in this this so-called hybrid
warfare have you seen it's like before
no i think that this is a very
perplexing war uh and it's you know very
local and regional up to a point i mean
the battlefields are all on the
territory of ukraine but it's certainly
a war
that's global in scope and meaning and
you know from that you can extract one
significant point which is that the
western response to the war in ukraine
has been much more critical of russia
than the global response uh so that's
certainly something that russia's going
to try to turn to its advantage and that
may be where some of this grain politics
comes into play
and it's interesting that that
the battle lines as it were in terms of
who's for and against uh russia aren't
clear you look at countries like india
or indeed turkey which has interests on
both sides of this
well that's correct also
brazil south africa and most importantly
uh china uh i don't think any of these
countries really strongly supports the
war or things that the war is a good
idea
but at the same time they don't strongly
oppose it they're not a part of the
sanctions uh regime and they are trying
to operate in their individual ways to
to benefit at times from being uh either
in between uh or closer to the russian
side so it's a very important part of
the picture
and what are the things that that has
perplexed a lot of observers has been
the lack of what would appear to be a
cyber response because
russia has been accused of exploiting uh
tactics in in cyberspace for years
disrupting elections and referendums in
foreign countries yet we don't appear to
have seen so much of this in this
current hot war why do you think that is
well not yet i mean don't forget that
it's early days for this war it's about
two and a half months old so we'll see
what the future brings
in this regard i think that there's one
clear explanation which is that russia
has undermined
a lot of the political support that it
had before the war so it doesn't have as
much to work with now
in terms of
you know information meddling uh
political meddling and such but where i
would anticipate cyber attacks in the
future would be on critical
infrastructure in places like poland the
baltic republics or perhaps germany or
the united states i don't think that
that's a science fiction at all it's a
it's it's a probable uh outcome if the
war continues to escalate
and a very um a very material uh way
that this has sort of spread out we've
seen russia switch off gas supplies to
poland and bulgaria and finland is due
is next on the list from saturday um
why do you think russia has picked those
particular targets well finland we know
but why why why start
with bulgaria and poland when there are
bigger a fatter fish
like germany or hungary
well poland has been you know really
front and center with this crisis it's
taken in a very large number of refugees
in poland as the country from which
weapons are flowing
into ukraine so i think it's just a
target uh for russian animosity and then
in other countries it's degrees of
vulnerability uh and degrees of of
leverage germany may be vulnerable but
it still has
lots of leverage bulgaria's in a
different situation
good talk could you thank you so much
for joining us sir michael kimmich from
the catholic university of america and
the german marshall fund
thank you for having me
[Music]
the germany's chancellor says qatar will
play a central role in his country's
plans to cut its dependence on russian
gas olef schultz made the remarks after
hosting the emir of qatar tamim bill
hamad
talks here in berlin qatar is the
world's leading producer of liquefied
natural gas and hopes to start sending
the fuel to germany by 2024. chancellor
schultz said germany would develop its
infrastructure to import lng by ship
and while germany prepares to do without
russian gas finland has had this uh
thrust upon it russian gas a giant gas
problems cutting off supplies just days
after finland applied to join nato
moscow says it's because helsinki's
refused to pay in rubles but uh gas only
accounts for five percent of finland's
energy needs and officials say there'll
be no disruption to consumers as
helsinki has already signed a
replacement deal with a u.s company
so let's explore this uh side of this
war with dr benjamin schmidt he's a
postdoctoral research fellow at the
harvard smithsonian center for
astrophysics he's also served as
european energy security advisor to the
u.s state department welcome back to dw
so russia says it's cutting phil and
daft because helsinki isn't paying for
this gas in rubles which of course was a
condition that moscow imposed in
response to western banking sanctions
but presumably we should read this as a
punishment for finland seeking nato
membership
yeah absolutely i mean i think that phil
we can we can see here this is just the
latest move uh in a long-running kremlin
instigated gas crisis that it has built
up in europe uh since mid-2021 all to
undermine the west's response uh to
russia's uh uh later
re-invasion of ukraine and we've seen
these cynical statements where gasprom
apologists and defenders people like
dmitry peskov people like former german
chancellor gerhard schroeder they
continue to perform implausible logical
gymnastics to try to explain away this
company's behavior is quote just
commercial and they really you know
represent kind of this extraordinary
conductors of a decades-long symphony of
absurdity
aiming to drown out anything that
doesn't harmonize with variations on the
kremlin's really farcical refrain that
quote russia has always been a reliable
energy supplier to europe i identified
on twitter just last week a thread with
over 25 different interruptions and
other non-market uh
actions and of course finland's uh
energy uh cutoffs uh last week
electricity and upcoming gas cut-offs
you know this this is right in that
wheelhouse
all right so germany is now uh looking
to qatar for its um for its uh lng
supplies but one wonders what sort of
bargain you can strike when the market
knows that you are desperate we'll hear
from germany's economy minister robert
harbeck and then we'll come back to you
it's it's obvious that we need
natural gas if we want to get rid of
russian national
natural gas this is the situation
but we won't be hijacked and if someone
is using this situation to
ask asking for two high prices or two
long term
contracts then we will find other
partners
benjamin schmidt that how done is this
deal with uh qatar is can germany
dictate terms or walk away
well they certainly can walk away i mean
the big thing to remember about lng is
that unlike oil it's less fungible but
it is going in that direction right so
it is it is something that you can go to
a global market uh and and try to
replace volumes and i think the most
heartening uh um act that i've seen
since uh uh you know since germany's
well-publicized zeit invented uh this
this supposed era of kremlin deterrence
which we you know haven't seen fully yet
but maybe things are going in the right
direction we saw minister hobick boldly
predict on may 5th you know a good
chance to do what is normally impossible
in germany instead to build an lng
terminal at wilhelm's often within about
10 months and connected to the german
gas supply and he also came out just
last week and called kremlin uh you know
kremlin energy practices is a
weaponization of energy or using energy
as a weapon this is something that was
unthinkable from the merkel government
and certainly unthinkable from former
german chancellor gerhard schroeder so i
mean it's it's really encouraging that
the physical infrastructure for imports
is being moved along quickly in germany
at the same time this sort of deal with
qatar you know this will take time to
work out but i think that it can be part
of the solution uh for uh for
diversification in germany and and i'm
really hopeful the fact that uh you know
we've seen these talks going on you know
this will take time but it's really
needed because
you know you have to get these uh gas
storages up there are many who would
query whether this is a deal that should
be done at all there's a horrific irony
about turning away from one dictator
waging a war on your doorstep to another
miles away in qatar with an equally
questionable a human rights record
yeah no doubt about that i mean this is
this is kind of the the uh you know the
curse that we have with hydrocarbons
this petro dictator uh and authoritarian
nations that are are are built on um you
know hydrocarbon sales and and that's
why we're seeing the same sort of uh
issues play out uh with the saudis with
the qataris uh with uh you know the the
the venezuelan government uh the the
russian government etc right this just
goes on and on and this is all the more
reason that we need to work to reduce
our energy energy dependence on in
particular authoritarian nations and and
try to diversify energy supplies to the
greatest extent possible right and so
presumably then in this circumstance
berlin's not in a position to impose uh
conditions ethically or otherwise
it's not clear i mean it's it's you know
it's a little bit different from these
long-term contracts that berlin had uh
in previous governments tried to build
in remember as the rest of the european
union from 2015 after russia's initial
invasion of ukraine was working to
actively diversify away from uh over
dependence on russian natural gas in
particular but energy in general germany
took the other approach it followed this
flawed host politic policy where it was
trying to actually entrench its energy
relationship through the now defunct
nordstrom 2 pipeline and these are the
sort of things that germany is actively
moving away from and getting onto the
global market is is really you know a
big big step uh it's something that
other countries like poland and bulgaria
and others which i heard you talking
about earlier they've already taken
those steps germany really needs to take
a page out of their energy security
playbook uh to become more resilient to
kremlin pressure
as ever good talking to you thanks so
much for joining us uh dr benjamin
schmidt from the harvard smithsonian
center for astrophysics